so you finally got your new sweet guitar
and you've got all the gear to go with
it and then you crack it out and you
play it and there's nothing worse than
it sounds like this
okay if you can't quite tell what's
wrong with that guitar it's completely
out of tune okay now admittedly it might
take a while for you to get used to okay
what does a guitar sound like when it's
in tune but usually if some things don't
sound quite right that's probably the
most likely explanation okay so
how do you tune a guitar
well i'm going to show you a couple of
methods in a second
but first let me explain how often
should you tune your guitar there's a
lot of factors that come into play so
for instance just when time passes um
the guitar will go out of two so unlike
a lot of other instruments like say
piano i might stay in two for
weeks months probably not years but it
can still sound pretty good after a
while but you know after a few days
depending on the kinds of conditions as
well which i'll say in a second um
guitar can very easily go out to you so
even if you haven't touched it
um you need to watch out um your guitar
probably have gone out of tune naturally
secondly how much you play so if you
play a lot the more you play the more
attitude your guitar will go and the
reason why is that when you strike the
strings
you're pushing on them and you're
pulling them so that they sort of unwind
as it were so usually a guitar will go
lower in pitch that's how it will go out
of tune sometimes they go higher but
i'll explain why in a second and that's
not as common
thirdly following on from there the
harder you play the strings the heavier
your playing style is the more your
guitar will go out of tune
um and so
watch out if you're if you're finger
picking you probably won't notice it
that much because you don't pluck them
that hard but if you're you know playing
with a pick and you're going really
heavy at it it might go out to you you
know within
15 to 20 minutes of actually playing it
um it's definitely common i know that
people might um two [ __ ] are up
and then rehearse for a little while
with say the rest of their band and then
they think fine great sounds good and
they put it down and then when they get
back up to play it sounds awful and
that's just because of
you playing freely while and will
naturally grab it through use
fourthly the quality of the guitar and
the quality of the strings will also
define how long your guitar stays in
tune so generally speaking a better
guitar
and higher quality strings will stay in
tune for longer
and lastly a tricky one which people
don't often think about
but the temperature of your guitar and
the temporary surroundings and
particularly changes in temperature they
will really take a guitar at it's you
because
those strings are made of metal
so heat and all that kind of thing
or cold will make the strings expand or
contract and that'll change the tension
which is what will affect the tuning
part so a really common example in
summer for instance you want to go
somewhere
and take your guitar with you so you pop
the guitar in the car but uh the boot is
probably really hot so it heats up in
the 20 30 minutes you're driving and
then you go back to your ride or
wherever you're going to play guitar and
it might be air conditioned because it's
summer and the cold temperature uh will
change your guitar to you again in fact
it might even if it's really sudden it
might make some of your streams snap so
change the temperature
they're a really big factor
when you need to think about how often
should i choose my guitar
right now how do you actually tune it
well the easy way as i mentioned before
is you should use a tuner so this is a
vibration tuner if you have one of those
fridges which you just either plug into
your guitar or sit in front of the sound
hole that's fine but if you have a look
at it
um and this is the display is too small
for you to see but all it will tell you
is
what screen you're playing
string is reasonably close to where it's
meant to be
and it'll tell you whether your string
is sounding too low so if you want to
sound a little more musical you can say
too flat
or if it's too high in which case you
need to make the sound a bit deeper so
as you play through for instance uh if i
play the bottom e string now
uh my tube tells me that sounds fine
okay so i'm going to go progress up the
strings and as it tells me it'll as it
as it hears the string it feels the
vibrations it will tell me whether i
need to increase or decrease the pitch
so this a
is a bit flat so i'll just increase it a
little bit here
when you're 2d it's really important
that you're really really gentle with
how you turn these heads in fact you
hardly turn them at all usually
unless your guitar is really really out
of tune and even if it is really out to
you
you shouldn't turn them quickly because
that change in tension might actually
make a guitar string set
so the d
that's pretty that's pretty flat
if you are one of the people lucky
enough to have perfect pitch then you're
probably able to hear this and hear
what's wrong without actually being a
tuner but i'm not one of those people
you can hear the change in pitch
so i didn't i hardly turn the um machine
head at all and there's quite a drastic
change so that's the way that they're
designed be subtle when you change the
strings
this is flat
that sounds pretty good okay now once
you've gone through uh and choose all
your streams particularly if number one
your streams are brand new or number two
you haven't uh to your guitar for a
while it's worth going back through all
the strings
to make sure they sound okay because the
any active 2d substrings the other
strings they've gone back out of tune
and the tension of each string actually
affects the others now once you've got
all six strings two you should play a
chord um
to make sure it all sounds good together
because strings can sound individually
fine but together not
okay so that's how it works with a tutor
now uh it's important to know that even
the tune is great it's fast it's
accurate um you'll need you ought to be
able to uh to the guitar without a tuner
particularly if you want to play in a
band now the main reason for that
is that right now
my guitar is what's called absolutely
two so
this
this e down the bottom is precisely an a
well according to my tune so if you've
got perfect pitch you should be able to
recognize that right and the rest of the
strings are precisely due to whatever
the notes are meant to be but if you're
playing a band particularly if you're
playing with a piano which is very
common
the piano itself may not be absolutely
tuned in that's very likely because 2d
you know takes a long time it's very
expensive
so
it's no use if your guitar and your bass
guitar or whatever other instruments you
have are absolutely tuned and sound
perfect on their own
and the piano that you're playing with
which is a major instrument which is
going to define the entire band is in a
different shooting
so
usually instead you'll want to tune your
guitar rather than to a tutor you'll
want to tutor to whatever the piano is
playing okay so how do you do that now i
i don't know how to play piano but all
you need to know to to the guitar off a
piano
is more or less to play one note um
the rest of the guitar according to that
um you can two individual strings on
your guitar to individual notes on the
piano that works too but this skill is
useful and i'll show you how so
most people start with the bottom e
this one okay so you want to find where
the e is on your piano um if you
have a pianist friend you can tell them
ask them to point it out to you um or
you can just go along and play that
until you hear the one which sounds
closest to your e that's probably it
unless your guitar is just drastically
added to you
now
as you strike that note on your um if
your piano has pedals uh if there's a
lot of keyboard it should be nice what
you want to hold down is the rightmost
pedal because that will make your the
notes that you play the piano stay which
would be helpful when we're trying to
listen to them so this is the e that i'm
after
okay now you've got to practice your
ability to listen to that turn it nice
and loud if you can
and as you play it
you want to play your note alongside it
and then you can compare the two so this
is what i'm listening for
now i want them to be as close as
possible together now just for instance
if i put this e out of two like so
so
now i'm not sure if you can tell the
difference to do that but that's quite a
lot more flat then as i play it
alongside i mean if i played it on its
own you might not know
that it's wrong but as i play it through
this e
you hopefully can feel that something's
not quite right so if you don't have
that much experience you're not sure of
should i go up or should i go down
you should play the note
and then you should try adjusting one
way or the other and you will feel it
sound better or worse so if for instance
i played my e
and i wasn't sure whether i should go up
or down suppose i went down
you can feel it's going further away
so that's how you go so you want to
bring it back up closer
until
you feel happy with how they sound
together okay
now like i said this is very you might
want to match it to the end it's on the
piano you could then go ahead and play
the a
that's on the piano and then the d and
then the g and then the b
and go on like that
but alternatively this is a useful skill
anyway now that you've got one string
the other five strings according to this
one string so here's the way that it
would work
on the e right if i if i play further up
the fretboard i can make the e string
play a different note so e turns into f
f sharp
g
uh g sharp
and on the fifth fret which often will
be marked over the dots that's easy to
pick out um i should be making my e
string play an a
that should be an a now therefore i
should be able to compare
this a with the
so i'm going to hear this kind of sound
so you want to compare those two
together just like you're comparing the
notes on the piano okay now once you get
to a satisfactory point you feel like
they're about as close together as um as
i can get them to be you move on to the
next string and you use exactly the same
trick so this a string
if i move up the frets to the fifth fret
again
it's now i'm going to play a d so you
can see most of the strings on a guitar
are one two three four five semitones
apart there is an exception but i'll
show you in a second so on the second
three
hold down the d
or down the fifth string and then play
the next string along
and see if they sound about right
do it again for the d if you hold it
down at the fifth fret you'll play a g
okay now
once you get that uh satisfactory moving
on to the next street is a little bit
different because this is the g
as you go up the notes you go g
g sharp
a
b flat and then on the fourth fret not
the fifth fret it hits a b
so when you're playing when you're
trying to tune up the b string
you don't want to hold the fifth fret on
the previous string you want to hold the
fourth one that's the only exception the
rest of them are fine even if you don't
remember that and you play the fifth
fret instead
you'll be like
okay that's definitely not right so that
you go back and forth
and that sounds better
then lastly uh on the b you want to go
all the way up to the fifth fret again
and it's going to play an e which you
compare
now you can imagine because you're going
down the streets or up the streams
depending on your perspective
if you have a little bit of error as you
go from string to string by the time you
get to the highest e string um it's
going to if there is any error it's
going to compound so that's why after
you play the six strings you should play
a chord
sure it sounds good together because if
it doesn't go back and you should check
it okay now one of the ways to know
which street is it which is causing you
problems number one more likely you have
problems down uh you know on these these
higher streams because
there's more error compounded but also
these middle strings the d and the g are
often also conference so play a chord
that you're familiar with go through
each of the notes individually like so
because even though you might not be
able to pick what you're going through
like this
you may not be able to pick which ones
which which one's off when you play the
chord because we play them so often we
have a really good sense of how they
ought to sound and you'll be able to
pick out them
off screen much more easily okay
so that's how you choose guitar um there
are other ways to choose half for
instance if you rather than holding down
a fret if you just put your finger
lightly over the 12th fret of any of
these strings for instance here
and that's called playing a harmonic you
can use that
uh to
actually tune in different ways so this
is the way luthiers who um who build and
design guitars they play uh two guitar
rather going uh one two three four five
six
they actually go in a different order
which i used to know but i haven't
really
used the method all that much recently
because i have a tutor and it does me
fine but you can look it up you know go
at the 12th fret which goes to these
sorry the 12th fret
harmonic which goes to the second fret
on the d because it's an e to an e it's
one octave
and then you can tweet it just the same
way you're comparing the sounds they say
that way the luthier's method is a bit
more accurate but it is trickier because
you've got to know there's a whole order
of strings that you need to have and you
have to hold down the string in order to
shoot it but apparently it gets better
results if you want to chew with
attitude
so
uh in summary make sure you tune your
guitar often it'll uh make your playing
sound so much better and um make sure
you learn how to tune to an instrument
so that when you're playing an event
you're actually useful and you add to
the sound of the bed rather than taking
away from it